WILL BE IN THE ROOM AND LIVE
WHEN IT BEGINS.
>> Joh ARKANSAS REPUBLICAN
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
I WANT T ASK YOU ABOUT THE
MIGS, POLAND SAID W WILL GIVE
EM TO YOU, UNITED STATES,T
RAMSTEIN AIR BASE FOR YOU TO DO.
HERE IS HOW JEN PSAKI TRIED TO
EXPLAIN HER WAY OUT OF THAT NOT
BEING A GOOD IDEA.
>> I THI IT'S PRETTY CLEAR IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE A MILITARY
EXPERT TO UNDERSND WHY HAVING
PLANES FLY FROM A U.S AIR BASE
TO A CONTESTED PART OF THE
COUNTRY WRE THERE IS A WAR IS
NOT IN OUR INTEREST AND NOT IN
NATO INTEREST.
>> John: SHE SAID I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW IT'S IN OUR
INTEREST OR NATO INTEREST TO
SEND FROM AN AMERICAN AIR BASE
TO UKRAINE, BUT FINE TO SEND
THEM FROM THE POLISH AIR BASE
INTO UKRAINE.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HERE, IT'S
MORE DITHERING, HALF MEASURES.
WE HAVE SEEN IT TIME AND AGAIN,
WHETHER IT WAS ON CENTRAL BANK
SATIONS OR INTERNATION
PAYMENT SYSMS KNOWN AS SWIFT,
RUSSIAN OIL IMPORTS.
ADMINISTRATI DOESN'T WANT TO
DO SOTHING, AND THEN ULTIMATELY
THE NATO ALLIES.
ADMINISTRATION SAID TWO DS
AGO, WE WOULDIVE A GREEN LIGHTT.
POLAND SAID WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
DO IT BECAUSE WE E SMALLER
THAN YOU ARE, AND RIGHT NEXT TO
RUSSIAN A WAY YOU ARE NOT,
ADMINISTRATION SD NO, WE COULD
NOT DO THAT, IT WOULD BE AN
ESCALATION.
W WOULD IT BE TO TRANSFER THE
POLISH AIRCRAFT AS OPPOSED TO
POLAND, A NATO ALLY T TRANSFER
THEM.
AND BIGGER THAN THIS AS WELL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE POLISH
AIRCRAFT.
THERARE OTHER EASTERN EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES IN THE WARSAWACT
THAT HAVE OTHER KINDS O
AIRCRA.
THEY HAVE OTHER KINDS OF
MISSILES, OTHER KIN OF ENEMY
AIR DEFENSES THAT WE WOULD
PROBABLY LIKE TO SEE TRANSFERRED
AS WELL.
SO, TS IS GOING TO PLAY OUT,
TIME FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
OP SLOW ROLLING THINGS, STOP
ASKING LAWYERS TO TAKE THE LEAD,
IT'SIME FOR LEADERS TO TAKE
THE LEAD AND THAS WHAT
PRESIDENT BIN NEEDS TO DO.
>> Sandra: SENATOR, WE LOOK AT
THE SITUATION ON THE GROUND
THERE AND SRY I'M LOOKING
DOWN, TING TO GET BRAND-NEW
DETAILS ON THIS HORRIFIC
SITUATION IN MARIUPOL OF THE
MATERNITY WARD THERE AND THE
WAINGS THERE ARE CHILDREN IN
THE RUBBLE AND HOWORRIFIC OF
AN ATTACK THAT IS, AND YOU JUST
WOER WHAT THEOURS AND DAYS
OK LIKE AHEAD AS BENJAMIN HALL
WAS JUST REPORTING TO US THAT
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY KYIV IN THE
COMING DAYS, IN FACT 24 HOURS
FROMOW IS THE ASSESSMENT,
COULD  UNDER A MUCH DIFFERENT
TUATION THAN IT IS RIGHT NOW.
>> SANDRA, THIS IS WHY WE ARE IN
A MATTER -- SITUATION WRE IT'S
NOT DAYS THAT MATTER,OT EVEN
HOURS, BUT MINUTES, AND EVERY
MINUTE THE ADMINISTRION SPENDS
WITH LAWYERS, TIN KERRING OVER
DETAILS WHETHER WCAN TRANSFER
STINGER MISSILES, POLAND CAN
TAKE THE AIRCRAFT, THIS THAT
ANDHE OTHER STEP, THE RISK OF
UKRAINIAN LIVES LOST.
THEY NEED TO START MOVING AT THE
SPEED OF WARFARE, NOT THE SPEED
OF BUREAUCRACY TO HELP THE
UKRAINIAN ARMY AND THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE DEFEND THEMSELVES FROM
THIS BRUTA AGGRESSION BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> SENATOR, L ME JUST SWING
BACK TOHE MIGS BY RAISING THIS
IDEA.
RUSSIA WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THIS
ABOUT A CONFRONTATI BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND THE UNITED STATES.
THE KREMLIN MOUTHIECE SAID THE
UNITED STATES IS WAGING ECONOMIC
WAR AGAINST RUSSIA
DO YOU EXPECT RUSSIA WILL TRY TO
RETALIATE ECONOMICALLY, AND IF
THE UNITED STATESERE TO TAKE
TH POLISH MIGS AND TRANSFER
THEM FROM RAMSTEIN TO UKRAE,
COULD RUSSIA SAY A DIRECT ACT OF
AGGRESSION BY THE UNID STATES
AND SPREADHAT INFORMATION
ACROSS RUSSIA TO SAY WE TOLD YOU
THE UNITED STATES WERE THE BAD
GUY IN THIS.
>> JOHN, THEY MIGHT SAY THAT.
BUT HOW IS THAT ANY DIFFERENT
FROM PROVIDING UKRAINE WITH
ANTIANK MISSILES KILLING
RUIAN SOLDIERS OR MISSILES THAT
AIRCRAFT.
IF WEIT BACK ON THE BACK FOOT
AND ALLOW VDIMIR PUTIN TO SET
THE TERMS, WEIGHT AS WELL SEE
ALL OF UKRAINE,EUROPE, AND
AMERICA AS WELL.
DEFEND AGAINST BRUTAL
AGGRSION.
ADMINISTRATION POSTURES REMINDS
ME WHAT GRANT DID I 1864,OOK
OVER THE UNION ARMY AND THE
GENERALS OF THE ARMY OF THE
POTOMAC AFTER THREE YEARS OF
FIGHTING RERT E. LEEERE
OBSEING, AND GRANT SAID I'M
TIREDF WHAT YOU THINK LEE WILL
DO.
YOU THK HE'S GOING TO TURN A
DOUBLE AM -- SOMMERSAULT, WE
SHOULD GET ON THE FRONT FOOT,
QUIT DITHERG, HESITATING, AND
HELP THEEOPLE TO DEFEND THEIR
TEITORY.
>> Sandra: I QUOTEELENSKYY
SAYING PEOPLE, CHDREN ARE
UNDER THE WRECKAGE IN MARIUPOL
CALLING IT AN ATROCITY, A
TALKING ABOUT THE BLOCKING OF
HUMANITARIAN AID, AND SAYING
RUSSIA ARE HOLDING HOSTAGE
MORE THAN 400,000 PEOPLE, WHAT
DO YOU MN WHICH SHOULD BE ON
OUR FRONT FOOT
HOW SHOULD WE RESPOND?
>> TAKE FOR INSTANCE THEOLISH
MIGS.RATHER THAN WAITING FOR PO
TOAKE ACTION, OR OVERLAWYERING
TH SITUATION, WE SHOULD BE
ANING FORWARD, ENCOUGING
POLAND TO TRANSFER THE AIRCRAFT
AND ANY OTHER AIRCRAFT A
WEAPONS THEY H DAYS AG
SAME THING WITH OTHER FORMER
WARSAW PACT NATIONS LIKE
SLOVAKIA AND HUNGARY AND ROMANIA
AND BULGARIA.
THEY WANT TO SPORT UKRAINE
EVEN MORE THAN THEY ARE.
BUT THE UNITED STATES AND SOME T
AND CAUTIOUS ABOUT IT, THEY ARE
LESS LIKELY TO PUT FORWARD THE
SUPPORT, THEY ARE AT GREATER
RISK.
>> Sandra: JEN PSAKI WAS ASKED
ABOUT THIS A JEN GRIFFIN SPOKE
ABOUTTHIS, AND SHE SAID THE
HURDLES PROVIDING THE MIGS TO
UKRAINE, SHE SAID CARTING THEM
DOWN THE STREET IS NOT AS EASY
AS YOU MAY THINK.
THEY HAVE TO BE TAKEN APART AND
PUT BACK TOGHER.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PPLE WHO CAN
DO SO.
TO THAT Y SAY WHAT?
>> I WOULD SAY JEN PSAKI IS NOT
EXACTLY AILITARY OR LOGISTICAL
EXPERT.
AN THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
HAS A LOT OF LAWYERS AS WELL, TO
FINDS EVERY REASON NOT TOAKE
ACTION WE SHOULD.
THIS REMINDS ME OF 1973 WHEN
ISRAEL'S BACK WAS UP AGAINST THE
WAR IN THE YOM KIPPUR WAR, AND
RICHARD NIXON SAID EVERY PLANE
THAT FES AND EVERYLANE THAT
SHOOTS AND THAT HELPED SO ISRAEL
WAS NOT OVERRUN.
THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE DOI WITH THE
STUBBORN BUREAUCRACY.
>> John: A COUPLE WAYS TOET
THE MIGS TO RAMSTEIN, TAKE THEM
APART, B THEM UP AND OVERLAND
OR PUT A PILOT IN IT AND FLY IT
THERE AND THEN FRO RAMSTEIN
INTO POLAND.
BUT LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS THE
UNITED STATES CANNOT SEEM TO GET
OVER.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT OIL.THE BIS
BANNED THE SALE OF RUSSIAN OI
THE IMPORT OF RUSAN OIL, SOME
PRIVE COMPANIES WERE DOING
THAT.
BUT DOES NOT SEEM TO BE A
CONCRETE PLAN TO BACK UP THE
LOSS OF THE OIL.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL IS
REPORTING THAT WE HAV GONE, ARE
TRYING TO GO TO SAUDI ARABIA AND
THE U.A.E. TO GET THEM TO PUMP
MORE OIL AND WERE REBUFFED.
AND WRITING CROWN PRINCE AND
OTRS DECLINED T SPEAK TO
BI, AND CRITICISM OF AMERICAN
POLICY IN THE GULF.
THE WHITE HOUSE PUSD BACK ON
THIS SAYING OH, NO, HE TALKED TO
THE KING BACK ON FRUARY 9TH,
BUT THIS IDEA THAT WE ARE TRYIN
TO GET MORE O FROM SAUDI
ARABIA AND FROM DICTATORS LIKE
MADURO AND FROM IRAN TO BACK
STOP A OPPOSED TO U.S. ENERGY
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU?
>> NO, JOHN, IT WAS THE RIGHT
STEP TO BAN RUSSIAN OIL IMPORTS.
WE CAN START PRODUCING MOR OIL
HERE IN A MATTER OF WEEKS IF NOT
DAYS IF THE ADMINISTRION WOULD
STOP THE WAR ON AMERIN OIL AND
GAS.
WEROBABLY COULD HAVE GOTTEN
MORE PRODUCTIOFROM SAUDI
ARABIA AND MUNITED ARAB EMIRATE.
AND ONE OF AMERICA'S STRONGEST
ALLIES AND SUPPORTERS AND
PRESIDENBIDEN HAS GIVEN THEM
THE COLD SHOULDER THE LAST 14
MONTHS AS THEY ARE UNDER ATTACK
BYIRAN'S PROXIES.
AND AYATOLLAH IN IRAN, STILL
CHANT DEATHO AMERICA, A
MADURO, O GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
REGNIZE AS THE LEGITIMATE HEAD
OF STATE IN VENEZUELA.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS TURN TO OIL
ANGAS WORKE IN PLACES LIKE
ARKANSAS, LOUISIANA, TEXAS,
NORTH DAKOTA, D ENCOURAGE THEM
AND THEIR INVESTORS TO GET
AMERICAN OIL FLOWING IN.
>> MEAN, THAT'S THE CRU OF
THE ISSUE, RIGHT, WE ARE ALL
HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS, LOOKS
SO OBVIOUS, SENATOR, LOOKS SO
OBVIOUS THAT WE HAVE TON OF
THESE RESOURCES RIGHT HERE TO
TAPPED INTO, O NEIGHBORS,
CANADA, MEXICO, PLENTY OF OIL.
WHY ARE WE -- WHY ARE WE TALKING
OUT TURNING TO IRAN,
VENEZUELA, OBVIOUSLY HUGE
PRODUCING COUNTRIES BUT WE KNOW
BASED O THE LAST COUPLE YEAR
HOW WE CAN BE - WE CAN BE
ENERGY INDEPENDEN
>> IT'S MISTYFYING, UNLESS THEY
WANT TO FEEL GOOD ABO
THEMSELVESBOUT KILLING OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION.
IF THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
GREEOUSE GAS EMISSIONS, IRAN
AND VENEZUELA WILL CREATE MORE
EMISSIONS, THEY DON'T HE THE
ADVANCED SYSTEMS WE DO.
AND WE CAN HP EXPORT TO EUROPE
TO B MOR